foreign
Jeremy's in Jackson Tennessee Jeremy how
are you
doing well how are you Mr Dave better
than we deserve sir how can we help
uh so I am trying to
get rid of a massive amount of debt uh
on a vehicle it's approximately seventy
five thousand dollars and I am yes and I
am 22 000 under uh under trade-in value
it is a truck
um it is a 2021 Dodge Ram
um and it was a a false need that my
wife and I felt we needed whenever we
were getting ready to move uh we thought
we needed a truck in order to save money
on a U-Haul and moving companies
[Music]
um
so now that's incredible that we're
trying yeah now that we're trying to do
the the baby steps and get a hold of our
our debt I understand that this truck
needs to be to be gone what do you guys
make a year
our take home our net take-home is
approximately 105. holy grimoli
you owe 75 000 on a Dodge pickup
yes okay and you looked up the trade-in
value on Kelly Blue Book
yes and you got 50 000 bucks
yes did you talk to a dealer
not yet no
um that's my next step is to go in and
talk to a dealer did you trade a
negative equity into this thing
yes oh okay all right
yes it was
2021 it would have gone down 25 000 yet
no you'd probably make money off of it
yeah it was a it was a very
poor decision yeah that's an
understatement one that obviously should
have never happened that's an
understatement yeah and yeah when you
trade a 75 000 vehicle for a U-Haul
rental you you really you really
struggled you're really struggling with
math on that one yeah yeah so um okay
wow oh man I'm so sorry how old are you
uh I am 26 as is my wife okay you have
any money I know I guess not
no money
uh no sir no sir okay
like none saved yet
is this a Hemi
uh yes yeah
okay
and you are in Jackson Tennessee
okay
um so here's what you need to do first
is you need to learn a lot about the
Dodge Hemi truck Market I don't know a
lot about it but the the truck Market in
general is way up and it's not as up as
far as it was a few months ago
and because of the electric car craze
and the threatening of doing away with
nice big engines and trucks uh stuff
like the Hemi I have an unusually good
popularity
because those of us that are rednecks
that burn gas we want a big old honking
gas engine and that one is
okay
so the good news is you kind of got a
Colt truck you got a truck that a
certain segment of the population thinks
is unbelievably cool you follow me so I
I want you to poke around and find that
nuanced segment of the population and
let's figure out what they are paying
for a Dodge with a Hemi in it
um
so the um
let's pretend that you could get
62 for it
okay
which I'm going to guess and say it
might take four or five months of poking
around learning about where to sell it
how to sell it but that might be full
boat retail on the thing
would you pay for it actual sticker at
the time
I think it was
68 or 69. it's a 21 you said right
yes sir how many miles
uh it's currently got eight eighty two
hundred did you have you torn it up
no okay do not run it through the brush
treat it like it's a Mercedes okay
because you got to keep it in pristine
condition to sell it like new I like new
21 that it was stickered at 68 you might
get 62. I might be right yeah you're not
going to follow up I'm impressed at how
good I am at this
so I'm thinking you're going to do that
okay but you're still 14 15 000 bucks in
the hole you're 26 years old and you're
broke so you're still gonna have to go
down the credit union and borrow 15 000
bucks and buy a three thousand dollar
car
our two thousand dollar car for cash
right and you're on fifteen thousand
dollar debt and the fifteen thousand
dollars the amount of money you lose on
this truck
I want you to write it down I want you
to take a picture standing beside the
truck right on the back of the picture
print the picture out and keep it in
your file
I used to do this stuff I've done a lot
of stupid things and when I lose money
on something I call it stupid tax and my
young friend you are about to pay some
stupid tax because you were straight up
stupid when you did this and so you want
to remember it so you never do it again